hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wann
ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt denn ich habe
mir ein format überlegt was ich ziemlich
cool finde und was ab heute starten wird
und nein ich werde nicht holzfällen
obwohl ich echt gut dafür angezogen bin
ich werde nämlich karten diese kirche
ist magische baum gestoßen und das soll
nicht welche langweiligen rezepte sein
sondern ist ein gerichte seien die ich
in filmen oder serien gesehen habe und
nachkochen möchte das ganze heißt wie
schmeckt heute waren wir an mit dem
apfelkuchen von schneewittchen ich
erinnere mich noch ganz genau als ich
als kind diesen film gesehen habe fand
ich es so toll wie sie diesen hand
abgeschnitten und wie die vögel dabei so
geholfen haben und den möchte ich heute
nacht ich habe auch schon äpfel für
einen apfelkuchen braucht man natürlich
apple weiß ich ganz genau ob es damals
schon diese app begab die senivita
südafrika oder so aus aber kommen april
ist ab phyllis apfel wach wird zur
information ich orientiere mich
natürlich nach einem anderen rezept ich
werde ihn nur ein bisschen verändern so
750 gramm apple haben dann brauchen wir
noch 250 gramm mehl und da habe ich
vollkommen mir genommen weil ich glaube
dass es damals jetzt nicht so reines
mega bis heute gibt es waren die 50er
jahre als schneewittchen haus kam und
schnittchen spielt ja noch früher
da nehmen wir ganz normales borken
meldet ist oder wo ich auf jeden fall
sparen möchte ist zucker und da hat
glaube ich nicht so viel zu gehen und
auf diesem kleinen gesten zucker zimt
weiß ich dass wir schon damals auch
nicht aber zum so lecker bei apfel und
deswegen ein bisschen schäden davon
ohne eier ohne mich meinte so ungefähr
wie man zusammen was reden muss jetzt
fragt sich vor in welcher menge lassen
wir brauchen eine schale schritt eins
wir schälen entkernen und schnippeln wie
äpfel in kleinen stücken wir gerade hier
bei äpfeln sind wenn es eine lücke
gesehen über äpfel die werden wohl ganz
schlimm behandeln zurzeit also also
nicht so schlimm wie flüchtlinge
nein sie werden mit so einer komischen
chemikalien behandelt damit sie nicht
alt werden aber für den werden sie um
die haltung von außen sehen sie aber
nicht aus
ich glaube ist ganz cool es ist zwei
verschiedene sorten genommen habt weil
das schmeckt am ende doch recht aufregen
auch tiere die mir helfen ich wünschte
ich hätte
leonardos doch dazu wird es nicht kommen
ok geschichte erfüllt ist noch klein
schneiden und falls ihr nicht wisst wie
man äpfel schneidet so winfried ninja
ich bin das schneewittchen dass das
erste tier was mir helfen möchte nahm
möchtest du mir beim kuchenbacken helfen
ja oder nein
und jetzt müssen wir die geschnittenen
äpfeln zuckern hast du dir eigentlich
das schneewittchen am anfang vielleicht
nicht in die kinos gekommen wäre weil
die leute das für zu gruselig gehalten
haben also die kritiker krass oder ich
weiß es gab damals kinzel aber stetig
mal gucken ohne zink haben wir auf jeden
fall ob ich nun mädchen gesehen habe die
kinder die nach 2000 geboren wurden ist
das immer noch so ein ding das man als
kind schneewittchen und die ganzen dass
hierfür bekommt so dass jetzt alles
verloren dieser apfel sind groß mit dem
man gleich an weihnachten auch ich das
gut hier kuchen gemacht eine change act
jetzt brauchen wir uns sagt mir
vollkommen hat noch so was richtig waffe
ist schneewittchen hat ja auch kein lidl
wo sie alles um die ecke kaufen könnte
ja denken jetzt kommt 200 gramm butter
dazu mutter ab ich liebe mutter hat mir
verraten sie format idee gut findet und
wenn ja ob ihr vielleicht irgendwelche
gerichten achten kocht haben wollt satz
schon eine liste von sachen aber ich
lasse mich gerne noch weiter ins
berühren dann kommt noch ein ei dazu
tanzen
schneewittchen sie hat es ja auch nicht
beschwert der teig ist fertig mit teig
da muss jetzt erstmal halbe stunde in
den kühlschrank weil er sich ausruhen
musst du musst dich jetzt erst mal
austeilten mein lieber teig ich habe
eine decke für dich macht ihr denn der
folie damit da keine kühlschrank
aktivieren und solange der tut und so
lange wir zeigt sich ausruhen werden wir
unsere kuchenformen vorbereiten und zwar
denn wie butter einstreichen und
semmelbrösel oder so damit das gut
wieder abgeht
ja ich zeig euch jetzt mal ganz
verrückten trägt wenn ihr so eine
kugelform ab
könnt ihr stück backpapier auslegen was
dann von oben fest machen und dann war
da nichts dran also kleine stück von dem
backpapier und streicht über die butter
und das könnt ihr dann gut für die rente
cm bruder so an ran
wer die gut so unterteilt sich genug
ausgeruht und wir brauchen jetzt die
hälfte für den boden und weite
fragwürdig der boden sein muss ich habe
keine ahnung schneewittchen hat es nicht
erzählt währenddessen meine tiere so hat
der kommt jetzt erst mal nicht so
schnell wieder wenn ihr den boden
ausgelegt habe macht ihr jetzt noch
einen rand mitteilt haben wir auch einen
rand jupa vanessa dankeschön in diesen
rand füllen wir jetzt unsere äpfel
einfach rein auch unseren schneewittchen
abwickeln müssen jetzt noch den
restlichen teig drauf machen und ihn
schön gleichmäßig drauf teilen okay
er fällt natürlich nicht auseinander was
die vögel am ende mit dem kuchen machen
wo sie da den rand ein pieksen mache ich
mit
ich würde sogar sagen besser als das
original und am ende schreibt
schneewittchen mit dem überschüssigen
teig rampling und ich glaube das ist der
name von dem eiszwerg ich schreibe
wandel bei der coolpix s3000 stunden
später ist auch fertig ich weiß hier bis
lesen könnt wandel und so schnell gucken
muss jetzt für 15 bis 20 minuten in den
ofen und hoffentlich studiert er darin
nicht
ob man kleiner gucken da ist es
natürlich war ich bis in 20 minuten das
iza da sie ist der mann fürs leben
kuchen porno gucken gerade noch mal
aufgefallen dass der kuchen ja gerade
wunderbar zum herbst passt zu fall
ich denke nicht der grosse moment ist
gekommen und ich finde dadurch dass er
so rustikal aussieht und aus vollkommen
sowas gemacht ist sie da echt aus als ob
der zurzeit von schneewittchen gebacken
wurde
jetzt müssen wir uns natürlich der
wichtigsten frage stellen wie schmeckt
seht ihr das schild dadurch ist er
vollkommen mehlis und fast keinen zucker
schmeckt er halt mega natürlich wie doch
ein bisschen so aus wie das was sie
immer bei game auf stur und so als essen
haben wisst ihr was ich meine dass er
ein ganz eigenes rezept ist werde ich
euch das mal unten in die infobox
reinschreiben ungefähr was sie da tun
müsst ja gesehen
ich hoffe wirklich euch gefällt das
format und wenn ja dann schreibt mir
doch gesicht in die kommentare die ihr
nach gekocht haben wollte
es gibt mir daumen nach oben darf
behauptet ich hätte gern von einer alten
frau kaufen wollen
wir hoffen
ich hatte das video gefallen wenn ja
dann abonniert doch den kanal bis dann
nun gibt unseren abgetrennten daumen
nach oben